patrol cars for go-karts metro officers
hit the race track today with las vegas
families bianca holman shows us how
officers are building positive
relationships here
cruising with cops at the las vegas mini
grand prix
i just wanted them to have fun as always
i mean it's been a rough two years
so getting out being able to do
something like this with lots of other
kids in the community having the police
present
i just wanted to be fun for all more
than 100 people received a free spin
around the track side by side with the
las vegas metropolitan police department
it's all to help kids feel comfortable
around officers this also exposes them
as well to make sure that you know we
have a good rapport with the police
you know it's all it's not always all
bad families enjoyed games rides and
photo ops with mcgruff
connecting with everyone is important to
those called to protect and serve and
really build those relationships and
trust on a different perspective rather
than a call for service or a car stop or
something you would traditionally see on
tv captain timothy hadget also shares
the department looks for opportunities
to meet with the community monthly from
little league baseball and soccer teams
to first tuesday events the oklahoman
live local now
we are also learning the bolden area
command little league team needs your
help their equipment was damaged you can
help by donating on the lvmpd foundation
website when you do be sure to specify
bolden area command little league